what's going on you guys the Lego Batman
movie is hitting theaters and hopefully
we'll go see it and walk out of that
movie Fang everything is awesome a
complete look you in the eyes right now
but today we're going to talk about the
awesome and the not so awesome as we
break down the best and worst moments in
all of Batman's live-action theatrically
released film and we've got a couple of
cool dudes to talk about it with first
he is a writer for DC Comics writing
Wonder Woman 77 and he recently debuted
number one on the New York Times
bestseller list with his wonderful
charity book love is love mark and Ringo
oh good to see you again for you and I'd
like to welcome back a friend and
contributor to screen junkies Adam
laughing thanks so much for having him
love you back again so fellas Will
Arnett is back as the Lego Batman and
Batman has had a long history on screen
a lot of people forget that the first we
saw of a feature film including Batman
was back in what 1966 yeah there was
even before that there was a movie
serials but no one remember remember
early 40s early right yeah yeah whoa
what's the Batman suit look like in 1940
like something your mom made for you the
night before Halloween Oh like my
costume from 106 yeah exactly that that
really takes me back
Oh on that note we're going to start
with Batman 66 mark give us one your
favorite moments on that film there's
two moments that I think really stand
out a classic Batman of the sixties
moments there's the moment with Batman
is climbing up the helicopter he's got a
shark on his leg a rubber shark and he
gets back to shark repellent which is
glorious and there's also the famous
moment where Batman's got a cannonball
with a fuse burning he's running around
and every time he's gonna try and throw
it there's like nuns where he goes to
throw it in the water and there's a be
ducks around he's like some days you
just can't get rid of a bomb the tone
isn't necessarily the Batman everyone
loves but the tone of that movie is
pretty consistent so if you like gags
like that the whole movie is gags like
that so we had to wait 27 years for the
next incarnation of Batman to hit
theaters and that is Tim Burton's 1989
Batman Adam let's start with you
pheromones routes off my head is the
first time we see Jack Nicholson's
revelation as the Joker when he's in
Karl Grissom's office
call me Joker and as you can see a lot
happier he just shoots Grissom you keep
shooting him and shooting him and he's
trading this into a dance and it's just
a crazy good ol time for him I think it
was in that moment he really snapping
and we really see the full potential of
what Jack Nicholson was going to do with
this character for sure mark what's
another favorite moment from that one of
my favorite moments is the Joker's got
Vicki Vale everyone's been gasps and
Batman breaks through the skylight as he
comes down if Cape goes out and
basically the silhouette of a bat shape
yeah that is an iconic image from the
comic book and it really showed this is
not the Batman that you rot walking on
reruns and it's just just I mean I just
got goosebumps it's just a great visual
moment yeah very cool what's up one of
your least favorite moments from um
instead of being so chill the character
who killed Bruce Wayne's parents they
made a joker and to me it felt like well
we have to connect these characters we
have to really make these characters
sync up together so at the end you
really feel the emotion of them fighting
each other and I ruined that too because
technically Batman should retire after
he stops the Joker because he got the
people to killed apparently comic book
when you didn't know when Joe Chill it
was just a random act of violence that
to me made it more profound the next
ride of Michael Keaton Batman Returns
1992 Michelle Pfeiffer's performances
Catwoman's movie is just as good as
Heath Ledger in The Dark Knight my
favorite moment in the whole movie
amongst it was really hard to pick Bruce
Wayne and Selena are dancing and they
both realize who they are and their body
language if they have dates will sort of
freeze and she looks at him she's like
does this mean we have to start fighting
it sums up their whole relationship
about that and it's just such a
beautiful moment of character and a
movie about big broad craziness in it
yeah it really gives them movie a spine
of the two of them Adam uh speaking of
cattlemen yeah to me my favorite part of
that movie is actually her
transformation scene you start to see
here kind of like losing it a little bit
and then she goes and destroyed the
whole apartment and then starts showing
up the cat suit and you just see this
character the transition and then slowly
evolved throughout the whole movie I
so you guys had a little bit of
difficulty picking out some
less-than-stellar moments from these
early Batman films I think that is going
to become a little bit harder that we're
going to talk about Batman Forever 1995
we had Val Kilmer taking over as the
Caped Crusader Adam give us something a
job oh boy oh man forever so one moment
that has always going to set out for me
was the moment that Robin reveals
himself in the Batcave Riddler and
two-face to make a pretty lethal
combination figured you could use a hand
two against two or better odds that to
me was great because you know I grew up
watching Batman 66 on Khan reruns yeah
so being able to see Batman and Robin
together was great what the moment that
you liked appreciate the easy joke is an
apprentice well I think the Riddler's
green costume that's how the Riddler
should look at the came of the question
mark and look it's a green but there you
go but yeah that's it okay it ends there
all right mark let's turn to the
flipside the worst thing in this movie
by far is Tommy Lee Jones he doesn't
know what movie he's in his costume
looks like he stopped at Party City
before he drove the pine-woods like
filler string on his face
that's not his balls again no dropping
performer that stubborn refusal to
expire let's move forward to George
Clooney as Batman in 1997 Batman and
Robin give us a moment that was
tolerable the schumacher embraces the
artistry of the 60s and has these Dutch
angles and the crazy saturated colors
the costumes are great mr. Freeze's
costume is cool his mouth closed
visually I think it's a beautiful movie
for what it's trying to be nice no
there's definitely something to
appreciate there Adam talk to me about
something like from Batman or Robin
Arnold Schwarzenegger as bad as some
people say he is he really embraced the
cheese of it and he really just went for
it
The Iceman Cometh and he does kind of
make that movie while
sundae's what's something that really is
a low point of that film arc well I
think George Clooney George Clooney is
the weakest performance and I think he
looks like a deer in the headlights
almost seven minutes
never leave the cave without Adam
something that really stands out there's
me off bein pain is a character that I
love from the animated series from
reading the comic books I had to wait a
lot longer to get a version of Bane that
was a lot closer to the comics yeah but
man they really made his character a
dumb-dumb
honey clean up this mess we've got
company coming
[Music]
so after Batman Robin Batman got put in
the corner for a little while and but
thankfully he was resurrected in the
form of Christian Bale in 2005 Batman
Begins I'll go with the training montage
between Ra's al Ghul jacquard and Bruce
Wayne I think that yeah that's the way
it's shot the location the setting and
really we that's the first time we get
to really seek Batman in any sort of
training yeah you sacrifice your footing
for a killing stronger probably my
favorite thing in the movie is the
sequence when Batman rescues Katie
Holmes characters although and Rachel
does from the the asylum hospital and he
summons the bat what is that what's that
once again I love when Batman jumps from
one hi-yah because that's a better idea
it's very evocative of the scene that I
picked for the original scene Batman
Batman jump down and there's all these
fats everywhere and I like that
Christian Bale plays at Batman's just
barely containing his rage I swear to
god Adam let's go back around to you
what's something that stood out as a low
point in that film if I pick some that
was a little more on the technical side
it would be the way Christopher Nolan's
films action it's a lot of close-ups and
you kind of get lost you don't really
know what's happening at arizona yeah
yeah so I think to me that was probably
the biggest disappointment of Batman
Begins sure after Batman Begins
Christian Bale returned to the screen
again and the Dark Knight
so I think we all probably have the same
choice as what the best thing about that
movie is of course Heath Ledger
yeah Keith ledger Oh
performance that I could watch every day
and find something new and terrifying
he's creepily sexy he's old body
he's the engine of the movie the part
where he blows at the hospital is
incredible and they blew up our actual
real building there's so many beautiful
moments in there that hit me he would
have won the Oscar even if he hadn't had
died early I think that performance
there was no sort of sympathy vote for
that it's an amazing amazing performance
talk to me about a moment that you
weren't thrilled with from the dark
night again it's more of a technical
thing I thought the pacing towards the
third act it kind of did start to drag a
little bit and I felt like the movie got
a little too long mine is almost exactly
that I would have ended the movie when
he gets the Joker and Harvey's gone and
all that's left is the coin and you do
to face in another movie okay and the
last of Christopher Nolan's trilogy The
Dark Knight Rises again Christian Bale
returning as Batman Marc something you
loved from that movie I love bang mm-hmm
I love that in that I love that weird
atonal sort of oh yeah I don't know what
things going to do and if someone who
sees a ton of movies when characters
surprise you it's worth every penny and
and I so want an app on my phone that
makes me sound like that I pull that off
will you die it would be extremely
painful you're a big guy for you to that
end what are some things that you
thought a couple of moments or something
that should have been improved Marc
technical stuff like all those cops are
in the sewers for like nine months and
none of them have beard yeah and shave
out that sort of little detail something
like on that scale drives me crazy
uh-huh absolutely Adam for me it's uh
Bruce Wayne's return to Gotham City how
the hell did he get back into the city
considering that city is on lockdown and
it's being monitored as heavily as it is
by Bane's army I know I know that I must
excuse everyone like ah Batman V
Superman with Ben Affleck taking over
the role of Caped Crusader Adam talking
about something that you loved so I will
go with the warehouse sequence where he
goes to save Martha that felt like it
was the animated series and the Arkham
video games come to life and I think as
fans
we had kind of been waiting for that
moment my moment is actually the tail
end of the moment after the scene when
he goes and he actually saves Martha
from being shot Batman has now seen the
light because Batman realized oh I can
be a hero and everyone else has
backstory let's shift gears and what are
some lower moments from Batman V
Superman Adam he shoots a tracker onto
the back of a truck
I was going through and thinking like oh
he's going to try to stealth his way in
there to try to steal the Kryptonite
no he just wrecks everything kills
everyone so I think they should have
made it more of a selfie Batman and then
slowly ease us into that warehouse
sequence gotcha
you guys we made it all the way from
Batman 66 to Batman V Superman what a
journey it was well history yeah so what
did we leave out what are some of your
favorite moments what are some of your
least favorite moments about any of the
movies we talked about this let us know
in the comments section below we want to
know I want to thank these two guys for
coming in and dropping some knowledge
mark and Draco Adam plavix thank you for
being here also mark you wrote a Batman
related comic
I did i did i did in diddy i'm
co-writing with Jeff Parker Batman 66
each Wonder Woman 77 you know there you
are oh wow awesome thank you marker um
did you bring me a present that's a
thank you so much for ellos for the
great conversation and for being here
and thank you for watching I'm Hal Rod
neck hit me up on Twitter bye bye hey
guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more